chaque fois qu'elle en a besoin cybèle
enfile ses bottes et pas récolter ces
denrées directement au potager f rien
autres comme ça c'est vraiment il ya
l'odeur de la terre il ya l'odeur de la
carotte qui dégage quand on les enlève
ce jardin a une particularité il est
entièrement 1 permet culture une
production qui profite des ressources de
la nature et se passe complètement de
produits chimiques comme avec cette
petite mare implanté au milieu pour
attirer les grenouilles elles sont
venues tout seul tout seul et ce
qu'elles font balade dans le potager
manger les petits l'animatrice est ici
de naturel en fait mais en rythme avec
la nature depuis un an la cheffe de
cuisine et son mari se sont lancés dans
cette aventure
les premières récoltes ont été réalisés
durant l'été et le domaine s'est ouvert
à la clientèle en septembre j'avais un
potager côté des gamines en bio entre
guillemets on a fait face à biot à
l'époque c'était juste normal c'était
naturel c'est comme ça que je continue
et ça c'est une étape encore qui va
encore plus loin
faut donner plaisir à nous et surtout le
client maison qu'ils consomment et qui
participe sorte avec nous cette aventure
un projet d'abord imaginé sur le toit de
leur restaurant à boulogne billancourt
mais trop difficile à réaliser
ils se sont alors mis en quête d'un
lopin de terre dans la campagne
francilienne et sont finalement tombés
amoureux du domaine les bruyères à
gambais plus qu'un potager ils ont
installé un restaurant gastronomique la
cuisine c'est comme le potager c'est une
cuisine vivante rien déjà qu'avec à la
vue c'est une cuisine qui vit passer des
plats cuits et après quand on
boots et plage et bien c'est une cuisine
qui apporte différentes saveurs tout en
gardant en fait le produit en bouche en
cuisine suis aussi dans un engagement
anti gaspillage donc par exemple ce
projet une petite carotte vous allez
faire rôtir les plus grosses carottes
j'ai fait en juin et ensuite j'ai réduit
je vais faire un petit vinaigrette sac
en main c'est un peu siro peu pour
accompagner cette carotte rôti une
ricotta maison et un oignon roses du
jardin
chaque élément de la carotte et
retravailler avec des fanes de carottes
je fais un petit piste où même les
fleurs de la carotte servent pour la
décoration accompagné de capucine pour
ajouter un goût poivré
le but c'est d'avoir une harmonie dans
l'assiette avoir différentes textures
différents goûts pour qu on s'ennuie pas
c'est comme une petite voyage avec tous
les différents éléments et pour partager
leur havre de paix jusqu'au bout il
propose cinq chambres d'hôtes qui
préfère nommer chambre de campagne dont
chacune porte un nom d'arbre histoire de
dormir dans un boulot et déguster les
plats de cybèle directement issu du
jardin